all right tabitha
yes tabitha where'd you girl where are
you from originally um
i was born in huntsville texas i grew up
in albuquerque new mexico
and spent that time there until i was
about 18
then moved to colorado it's been about
12 years there
then i came out here about three years
ago and tell me about how you grew up
you had both your mom and dad
um actually um up until i was about five
years old i kind of grew up with both
parents
more spending most of the time with my
was it my paternal grandparents my dad's
parents
um not such a great thing um
after that about six years old i
actually started
being put in treatment centers so i more
grew up in the system than i did with my
parents
what was going on at home um i guess
according to
what everybody said i had a lot of anger
problems
just behavioral problems just acting out
being violent was there abuse going on
um
from the eight well i guess from my
understanding like from the time i was
like
about in diapers until i was about five
years old i was like
molested by my grandfather so
i guess that's where a lot of anger
stemmed from sure being violent stuff
like that
uh after that my mom just had a lot of
boyfriends in and out
she uh boyfriends that were abusive
um physically
a lot of still a lot more molestation
going on stuff like that
right and uh you went on your own at
what age
um i actually got emancipated three
months before i turned 15.
i got pregnant at 13 though i have
a boyfriend that i had um
it was just a boyfriend that i had been
dating of course i lied about my age i
looked older than what i was
he was 17 i was 13
got pregnant 13 i had my son at 14.
i had my son january 21st of what was it
2002
and you you start with drugs
um i started using drugs when i was 11
years old
i started drinking and smoking weed um i
didn't really get into any hardcore
drugs until i was about 15
16 years old um drinking though
became one of my worst problems um
i was able to drink like a gallon of
like everclear
um in a 24-hour period by myself wow
i wound up with four bleeding ulcers i
found out a month after my 16th birthday
so is the alcohol still here
um actually i made sure to stop drinking
um the more kids i kept having it was a
little bit harder to
always drink like that and then continue
to go through the detox and everything
um so i just kind of quit drinking for a
while and i drink once in a while now
but
um smoking weed was always still my
thing
i got into smoking rock for a while um
i stopped doing that i mean anything i
did i did on my own
i've never i've been to a few rehabs but
rehabs really aren't my thing if i
wanted to quit i was going to quit if i
didn't i didn't
um i guess my biggest thing is just my
behavioral
my behavioral stuff i get very violent i
have a very short temper
um i became a very big introvert
but out through after my course of life
i've also learned to
if i want to know something i've learned
it i don't
leave it upon other people to teach me
it i'll pick up a book i'll go online
and i'll learn it it's easy to learn
nowadays it is kind of
back then it was easy to learn as well
um it just matter if you want to
what is your drug today um i do crystal
meth sometimes still
um i still smoke weed like crazy so yep
and uh yeah how many kids do you have
i have six six kids i have six kids and
one grand baby
are you raising any kids um i was um i
came out here to california three years
ago
um and
the reason i came out here was because
my youngest daughter's dad
had tried raping me while he was like
extremely intoxicated
when i got to the hospital they wanted
me to leave the
state just to get away from him until
the court stuff got going
[Music]
so i did my mom had lived out here for a
while and
she had owned her own business so i came
out here but bringing five kids out here
was not really
it's not very feasible and or
price wise it's not good either sure
it's expensive so my kids are all at
that age to where they made the decision
they wanted to stay with grandparents
um stay in the town that they've been in
since they were born
so i told them they could make that
decision and i told them well mom's here
no matter what
so if you guys want to come out here you
know you can if you just want to come
visit that's fine too
you know i'd rather you guys be happy
and okay with what you're doing um i
have been i was
in and out of prison since uh right
before i turned 21
i was in and out how do you know um i'll
be 33 in october
and you're living on the street now
living on the street yeah yeah
i've been living on the street for
almost three years now
um how do you support yourself now um i
support myself in various ways by
um i've sold drugs to just hustling
whatever you can
yeah pretty much um the only thing i
haven't gotten myself into
is prostitution i just don't
that's just one thing i don't think i
could ever cross the line with and and
per se just because
it's just too much of a closeness to me
and due to being molested when i was
younger i'd
kind of like to keep that as more my
just me my personal thing
not trying to just share it with someone
and get paid for it i just don't
if i want to do it i want to do it if i
don't i don't i don't feel like
being paid for something like that is
just my thing to do
um i have done an escort thing but it's
more
not along the lines of any sexual stuff
it's just
they need someone to go with them for
dinner for a business thing um they just
want
company they just want someone to talk
to companionship more than anything
so that i can handle yeah
and do you have contact with your kids i
do you do my kids yeah they they hit me
up on messenger
um call me when they want to
stuff like that sometimes when i try to
call them instead of letting them call
me it's more
mom i'm with my friends right now gotta
go i'm like okay well screw mom
you know i don't see you that often but
okay go have fun you know
my son is 19 so um he lives in new
mexico
and he has the grand baby so
he made me a grandma she's like 15
months old now so
and looking back at your life what i
mean huh what what regrets do you have
regrets i have in life are
the parents you you chose not
yeah the path i chose just trying to
always think i could do everything on my
own
thinking that you know i don't need the
help when
i should have just taken the help and
stopped being so stubborn
even though i know how to learn on my
own sometimes learning from other people
i've learned out through my life
goes a little bit further than just
learning on your own
helps maybe to not take such a long path
i could have taken a shorter path and
not gone such a hard road
yeah and the the sexual abuse that you
went through with your mom's boyfriends
and your is it your grandfather
yeah that must have affected your
adult life now right um it does a lot in
a lot of ways like well especially with
my kids
i'm very cautious about where they went
to who they went to
even with family um any signs of
anything i was quick to jump on it to
say something to be like hey you know
what that's i don't find that
appropriate you need to stop like
you know it's not okay um my girls
i don't allow them to wear anything
short anything see-through they're not
even allowed to wear makeup and they're
already
14 13 and 12 are the older ones so
i tell them chapstick that's it don't
you put anything else on your lips don't
you're not allowed for nothing else
um stuff like that my 12 year old she
kind of doesn't listen so
she's kind of trying to be on facebook
and
um with makeup and doing
i consider inappropriate um
poses and stuff like that and i try
talking to her but she doesn't really
want to listen she's one of my
as i say my chunkier kids and i guess
she's having some problems in school
with
a lot of the kids and stuff like that so
she's kind of
battling being accepted and kids making
fun of her and stuff like that and
everything so
it's kind of a different path for me
because i've never had that problem in
school
and neither has my any of my other kids
so
you know she she puts things on facebook
like you know if i die today you know
where
would you be there what it is with that
i'm like baby what is going on with you
you know
it um it takes a big toll on a parent to
go through some stuff like that with
your child
absolutely especially when you haven't
been through it and stuff you know yeah
what emotions do you fight with um
i fight a lot with my anger emotions i
fight a lot with my own pride
um a lot of hurt um
a lot of guilt i know if i would have
made a few more better choices in life
i don't think that i would be quite
where i'm at today
but i know through where i'm at today
and the things that i've been through
i've grown a lot i've learned a lot
um people come up to me and talk to me
and tell me
about their life a lot i could just say
hi to someone and
next thing i know i'm knowing something
about someone's whole life story and i'm
just like
okay i guess you could say i feel like
dr phil sometimes i just don't get paid
for it
so did you get depressed sometimes um
depression i don't think is really
really an emotion that i have um i've
been diagnosed as a
sociopath and bipolar but with violent
tendencies so i go from being
okay to just being angry and being
violent
um how far is your violence
gone
[Music]
i've done a lot of things that i regret
um out of obligation i've
i've put a lot of people to the grave i
guess you could say
um
i've done a lot of things i guess i
still look over my shoulder with
i wouldn't say like i'm religious um i
do believe in god
and no matter how much i guess i can
say i have asked for forgiveness i just
i still look over my shoulder because i
know even though things have been out of
obligation i still
i still did wrong and i still did stuff
that i shouldn't have done
and i just wish i could have done things
a little bit better just not been in
situations to where i would have even
had to been obligated
to do such a thing but i guess you know
life takes its turns and sometimes you
just got to take that turn and sometimes
it's going to be rough and sometimes
it's not
and do you have friends no um do i have
friends
um i know you have street acquaintances
but i have acquaintances
yeah it's really hard to say that i have
friends i have a few people that i
consider my best friend
it's really hard for me to get a person
to call a person that
most of my friends yes are guys but
due to mine and my mother's relationship
females and me just
don't don't usually click very well
and your mom is raising your kids no my
mom
actually moved from here to texas about
a year and a half two years ago
and um she moved back to alvin texas
where she's from
uh she is more closer to my
my siblings um kids than anything um
my kids are with their um their dad's
parents
oh i see okay
in your relationship with your mom um
it's all right as long as we don't live
under the same roof
as each other we can live under the same
roof for maybe
about three days and then after that
it's my mom's narcissistic so
um it's very hard to be under the roof
of someone that's a narcissist um
but i love my mom dearly you know she's
had just like me had to make choices in
her life and stuff
and it's caused a lot of us uh minding
my brothers to go through things when we
were
younger and stuff like that um
but for the most part like we talk and
stuff like that now as far as my dad
last thing my father ever said to each
other was i hate you
and the day you die would be the best
day of my life
so not the best relationship no
no that's that it's not um i have been
through college and stuff like that like
i'm actually kind of
waiting for me to get my act a little
bit more together and i'm gonna go back
to but i'm gonna do college back online
and do my majors because i've already
done my general studies so i'll be doing
my majors
which is interior design decorating and
to become a psychologist major that
would be great yeah
i feel that i can there's a lot of
things i can help people out with and
i've done a lot of help out here in this
world but you know
i want to actually do it and do it
professionally and stuff like that
for you it's great what would you say is
the most important
thing you've learned in your life
patience
and love um
i say patience because
it takes a lot to deal with this world
nowadays this world has
became crapped in my in my point of view
um and in order to just deal with people
in general
and deal with how they are you have to
have patience you have to learn to just
sit back and just breathe for a minute
and just say okay that's their behavior
not mine i'm going to let this ride
um love because without love
i don't think any of us would be here
today
so all right tabitha thank you so much
for sharing your story
you're welcome and i wish you the best
of luck thank you thank you so much